[Music]
the haters always say Tonya tell the
truth there's no such thing as truth
everyone has their own truth I was the
best figure skater in the world at one
point in time call out a clean skate for
Christ's sake do not swear in front of
the kid I didn't swear you [ __ ]
[Music]
you to [ __ ] yet you need to see a
wholesome American family I don't have a
wholesome American family you skated
like a graceless bull dyke was
embarrassed for you my entire life I've
been told when the mouth see anything
you know what maybe I would we also
judge on presentation
suck my dick didn't even even the place
I know God shouldn't even be saying his
name Derek the press wanted me to be the
pilot crap I never did this
[Applause]
what is going on well with the FBI they
know something what can you tell us
about Tonya Harding I don't know it
totally hearted aren't you her bodyguard
when I was a kid did you ever love me I
made you a champion no one you'd hate me
for it that's the sacrifice a mother
makes accursed me America they want
someone to love come on what kind of
friggin person bashes in their friend's
knee who would do that to a friend
[Music]
[Music]